[Applause]
topics that we will work days in many
ways while trying to figure out some of
the deepest implications of what it
means to be a human being when we first
formed the OPF photo exhibition
fellowship last year one of the
discussions one of the very first
discussions we had at our weekly
meetings was one that dealt with how we
see ourselves today how we in our
society and especially a student have
lost something very basic about
ourselves and many currents of thought
and well certainly in our hyper
rationalized deconstructed postmodern
world one loses sight of the meaning of
not only those things which are external
to us but in the process we fail to
understand the very core of our being
many of you will know that recently dr.
Jordan adderson has faced an immense set
of controversy precisely for questioning
the documents of our ages and yet he has
also stressed the importance of the
divine individual and a Christian
concept of the logos which I will allow
our speakers elaborate upon today a dear
friend at school we want that was
fundamentally divides orthodoxy from any
other kind of ideologies is precisely
fit the dignity of the divine
individuals and what this means for us
as spiritual and physical beings and so
I'm immensely excited to hear what our
panelists have to say tonight and so I'd
like to introduce each of our panelists
starting with father Theodore Rob
Cavallo
who is adjunct faculty at the OSS school
of theology at Trinity College last
semester he taught a course on the human
person in Orthodox theology in Orthodox
tradition and in many ways is something
that touches upon or introduced its very
core above being discussed today
what is the individual what does it mean
to be human and he is also quite a
positive presence at our Constitution
fellowship and we certainly look forward
to hearing this perspective tonight
Jonathan hi Joe is a very well-known
icon Carver from Quebec as all Dan
editor for the Orthodox Arts Journal
many of us were familiar with
honest and is worth prior to this and so
it's a great pleasure to have them here
tonight and indeed it is entirely
appropriate
just this past Monday the Orthodox
Church celebrated in spirit of unity the
sunday of Orthodoxy the celebration of
our times over iconoclasm the tradition
of iconography in the Orthodox tradition
is one of deep theology and I'm very
pleased that an expert on the matter is
with us here today and many of you may
be interested to hear
Jonathan's online discussions with dr.
Peterson the most recent one being
concerned with one of the most
controversial political symbols of the
day the metaphysics of Peppe dr. Jordan
V Peterson is a professor of psychology
here at the University of Toronto and I
think it goes without saying that the
activism of dr. Peterson has inspired
many in the room today many who would
have previously perhaps not even
considered looking into the type of
concepts which are going to be discussed
today myself and many others have been
deeply moved by not only dr. Peterson's
insight on matters of a political nature
but also in this insight in human nature
the title of this discussion was
influenced by dr. Peterson beauty of the
concepts of the Christian concept of
logos and what that means for us as
individuals I'd like to thank dr.
Peterson for joining us and we are
greatly looking forward to hearing more
of your insight on this matter last but
not least father Jeffrey Reddy who is
the co-director of the Orthodox school
of theology the chaplain of our
Christian Fellowship and the parish
streets as the holy murmurs Orthodox
mission located at Trinity chapel from
the very creation of our opiates last
year father Jeffrey has continuously
blown our minds and intents our
understanding not only of our board of
spiritual life but of ourselves as human
beings apart from his remarkable natural
qualities his warm of knowledge in
perspective has made it only natural
that we would offer his perspective on
this panel tonight I'd like to thank
father Jeffrey for his work and greatly
look forward to very good perspectives
tonight so the format for the discussion
today will be basically that each of our
panelists
will speak for four time and this will
be followed by a question-and-answer
period each of you will have received
few parts and each row has about two
pens so for the duration of the
discussion you can write down your
questions and pass them up at the front
and then we'll try to get through as
many fun as possible by the end of the
night and with that I'd like to welcome
father Theodore crusty of office to the
podium to begin our discussion thank you
[Applause]
okay so there's not gonna be any mind
rolling okay
reserved with Walter Jeffrey thank you
to the ocf and VOT for asking me to come
and to be up here on the stage with
people that I kind of feel fill out out
back definitely but um I appreciate the
invitation so I was told speak like 10
to 15 minutes about what it means to be
a human person in your class tradition
so I don't know how possible that is but
vlad's just mentioned that in the past
two days on Sunday we celebrated in the
Orthodox tradition for Sunday of
Orthodoxy which is the first Sunday in
Lent for those of you who don't know
what that is or don't know what we
celebrating that day we celebrate the
return of the holy icons into the church
now a lot of people bend Orthodox
churches know that the church is full of
icons and they wonder well when was
there a return and why was their return
considering as if you ever not happen of
course Christians have had images in
their churches and in their bases of
worship from the very beginning but
there was a time that there was an
oppression of the idea of using images
as they were specifically idolatry in
the church and it was a faction within
the church that fought against it and
for almost a hundred years icons were
burned destroyed and taken out of
churches it was only the seventh
ecumenical council that they were
returned
of course why do we celebrate this on
funding
adoption what do we call it Sunday
orthodoxy is because those who are with
a proponent of icons and of course
called
Modern Orthodox Christians a day knew
that the attack on the depiction of
Christ was an attack on the Incarnation
itself the idea that Christ is an actual
human being
he actually existed actually lived and
lived he was an actual historical figure
lives at a certain time and not a
figment of our imagination as some
people today would say and this means
that when we speak about God and when we
speak about the Trinity when we speak
about the second person of the Trinity
who the son locals as we're speaking of
tonight we are speaking about a very
specific person and that is in contrast
to many of the discussions that we see
today both in the public forum online
symposia like this where many people
would like to think of God as an
abstract Orthodox Christian and I would
say for you know historical ancient
Christianity God is not an abstract or
rather God is an actual person there's
an objective reality there crisis an
objective person he thinks a certain way
speaks of certainly act a certain way
even look the Triple Aim and so we can
get pikmin at icons now the reason why I
started with this and I kind of you know
begin my thoughts is because there is a
little bit of a contrast between many
religions and orthodoxy this is not this
is generalization but as generalizations
go in many religions whether they be
Christian or not the concept of God or
the cost of the divine usually centers
around the idea of the Word of God
ëcause with the God made text and there
are usually writings about this and
writing the usually very ancient they're
passed down and the text is usually what
is focused on even amongst many
Christian denominations
it's all about the text however in the
Orthodox tradition it is not about the
word becoming tax advisor about the word
becoming flesh
I mean human being and so our faith is
not based on attached about it on a
beach mystical experience of the risen
Lord throughout time now you're going to
say well we read the Bible too right we
use the Bible we venerate the Bible we
have it in very high regard however or
ancient Touche
I love that because other Star Trek -
you know when we when we speak about
Christ which is about God
we speak about a living tradition Bryson
found a book neither did he found the
philosophy the rather he found is a very
real community a living community and
the earth our church the last 2,000
years is this living community that has
never stopped it has never ceased to
exist it was never a time where it did
not exist we have no beginning we have
no reformer we have no founder we have
no school of thought but rather we exist
from the very beginning so the reason
why I say this is because our concept of
God and our concept of our relationship
to him is a very intimate one and one
that is in living for the last 2,000
years
so going back to the idea of an
incarnation of theology of icons if we
are to say that God is real he actually
exists if we don't believe in not go
down they possibly never but if we
believe that God exists and that God is
an actual person if mind is personality
and that Christ is God in human form
then the reality is is that there is an
objective reality to who God is and by
that we can say that there's an
objective truth that we can speak about
and there is an objective good that we
can speak about and there is an
objective understanding of the human
being that it is not subjective a rather
objective and for us as work
restrictions we tend to follow the model
that was coin
by seeing Athanasius the great famous
fourth century father the church and
great theologian who said that God
became man so that we may become God not
going to come vo God but lifeline so for
us the goal of the Christian life is to
emulate Christ to become Christ light
it's not about what I think of myself is
not about what I want to be or was what
I like to create in my mind of what I
would like to eat or what I think I am
but rather that there is Christ and
Christ the perfect human being and I try
to discover what that is and I know that
is diametrically opposed to the society
that we live in today for the most part
for the most part that we live in a
society that is a society of
subjectivity not objectivity and we live
in a society that when it speaks without
religion or speaks about spirituality
and speech about speech about theology
it usually refers to the subjective
understanding of God a subjective
understanding of the human person as
Professor Peterson has begins in the
last few months so when we talk about
human identity it is it is something
that is to be discovered not to be kind
of created or self created so you know
there's a there's a writing as the very
early second century writing in the
church called bouzouki which means the
teaching one of the earliest writing to
the church I guess we could say is one
of the earliest manuals of how to be a
Christian or the basics of the Christian
faith I guess you could say it and in
the guy he it says the first line says
there are two ways one of life one of
death and there's a great difference
between the two it's the opening lines
and and really when it comes to you know
the the understanding of the human
person from North us point of view we
would say the same thing that there are
really two ways to understand there is
either the revelation from God and how
we emulate that or rather there's a
movement towards the cell
towards self-regulation self
understanding and really we would say
self idolization and and so of course we
as human beings are free to do whatever
you want you to do and we have free will
but how we use that and what what we do
with it and what we choose to become
really depends on where we're looking
towards what we want to do and then and
who we want to be so I would say that
the the modern existential crisis of our
time can really be remedied by the
simple statements that if there is a god
there's a God I'm not him so the
understanding that if there's God and
I'm not that him would mean that I
discover who that God is and what he
expects of me why am I here and what am
I supposed to do with my life and that's
diametrically opposed to the subjective
understanding of that God is whatever I
want or what I was rather him to be and
go from there
so in pre-modern Western civilization
society was predominantly you know a
society of these kind of values is kind
of objective truths it was kind of like
the social glue that provided stability
for the family and social institutions
and religion and and even business
ethics like people believed that there
was a good there was a truth out there
that we need to discover there was a God
that we needed to somehow figure out who
that God was and the humility that was
required to accept that we are not gods
was what held all that together in the
social and psychological fabric of
society so without it and this is where
I think pressure Peterson would also
agree and has said many times without
this kind of understanding of an
objective reality there is an endless
movement toward the individual toward
subjectivity towards what is relative
and ultimately to war
nihilism because if there is no
objective meaning in life and there is
no justice truth in life then and
everything is whatever I make it and
everybody is right and really everybody
is wrong and then really what you had
belittle so real ultimate meaning in
life and so this is the problem
no and there's a movement towards the
delusion that everyone is their own God
and everyone is free to create
themselves in their own image in this
grief endless fragmentation as Professor
Pierson has said of both so-called
individual truths and also individual
identities so if there is no God as you
said this conversation is only matter
however if there is a God and he is a
personal God as the Christians claim
then we cannot go on ignoring him
without suffering serious identity
crisis I believe that this crisis as a
rioter the question is how do we as
Christians continue to see the world see
the Word of God the divine logos in
those who refuse to see it in themselves
but how do we speak to that how do we
speak to a world that doesn't even
acknowledge that very special locals if
there is such an click recruiting person
this is this is the conundrum that we
find ourselves in the difficulty how do
we witness through a world that is not
speaking the same language and more and
I think that is are something that you
know discussions like this are extremely
important to attend the first steps
because here we are attempting and I and
I applaud the LCF for doing this
attempting to find points of convergence
between a Christian tradition Orthodox
Christian tradition and also a secular
approach psychology sociology history
biology places where these things
converge and they tell us and we preach
the same truth and this is why I was so
enthused about coming and speaking today
because watching a lot of attributions
videos online I saw that there are a lot
of points that he makes that not only
are in
ruined with Orthodox theology in
Orthodox anthropology but speak common
sense for the world in a world that is
completely fragmented a world that is
completely disengaged from the idea that
there can be a truth outside of
ourselves and that there needs to be
some type of speaking some type of
understanding of what that truth may be
the main difference between philosophy
and theology I always tell my students
is that philosophy comes from us it is
us trying to understand the world trying
to understand a bit of physical try
understand God understand anything you
can philosophize about anything but the
source of the human being we have this
wonderful thing called the mind is so
powerful they can do so many things but
that's philosophy theology deals with
revelation deals with what has been
revealed from outside the community from
someone else and that's what that's what
the church not to deal with that's what
the Christian is what the sharing I have
to deal with the idea of what God has
revealed himself by becoming a real TV
become one of us and we can't negate
that as much as we try and to do so we
mean to negate an important part of
ourselves because we believe as
electricians like to say all the time
and as I would like to quote Genesis
where God says in the very beginning in
Genesis 1:26 as God makes man in the
image and his license it gives us this
great ability issues its greatest
ability to reason and to figure things
out for ourselves and decide whether we
want to be like him or whether we want
to be more like something else so this
is the great dilemma it's not just a
theological dilemma it's not just a
spiritual dilemma
it's an existential dilemma it's
becoming a social dilemma become a
political dilemma a biological dilemma
and a lot of other goals so I will end
there I will let Paula Johnson take us
in here but I think this is a general
introduction to at least the way we see
it as Orthodox Christians like God
becomes man's that man should become God
also the words of the Apostle Paul they
what I live
I salute group of Indian this is our oil
from the pole
thank you very much other dead thanks
for appreciate I appreciate being here I
appreciate being in Toronto it's the
great